right it came on time I darling there
was no problem with the bosses we've
waited from seven o'clock in the morning
and the bus was on time so that's the
reason why we on time yeah okay yes that
we want to be here before you level and
related or anything is going to start on
time is it even so we are here to catch
the vibe that's the whole thing we want
the vitamin tell us below to love one in
display space in today completely wear
you down in there there's lots coming
down in there hi girls everything here
oh you're excited very excited we here
to pay our last respects to Nelson
Mandela and we woke up this morning and
we said we are pouring day one day with
the rain is yes nothing compared to 27
years in prison yes